[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
happy thursday a really good friend of
mine always says great minds think alike
or fools seldom differ well here we are
tapped into the group chat as great
minds
or a few april fools all presented by
fanduel
my name is kathy richards our betting
expert is kelly stewart and the man
responsible
for vibes is vegas greg his
hooligan nickname from kelly vegas greg
ivory no no bro we cannot let that ride
no that's not me bro no
vegas greg in the comments and i'll tell
one of the producers to get you guys a
hoodie
hey we need we need vegas greg that's
terrible i got it i got i'm going to
start the trend right now
vegas greg we're giving away hoodies i'm
hijacking your job greg
vegas jean let's get it for richmond g
to vegas g
here we go so we're a week removed from
the nba trade deadline and basketball
twitter is still
on fire the community on the br
app is on fire just click on sports
betting boom
click over to community uh i love this
or i saw yesterday from jameel williams
at meal
i need friends that give good tips well
meal
let me direct you to dietz 999552
greg and i tailed your blazers moneyline
pick last night
so thank you deets 9552 that's all in
the community app
so get in there join the community we
want to hear from you all right so each
week
the 3x2 greg assembles the winners only
army
please and it's vibey and it hits
uh the question is will there be two
three-pointers made in the first three
minutes of the game
we invented it it's scorching hot uh
like james harden with the brooklyn net
so
uh check it out both on tuesdays and
thursdays last week
you guys elected that we go with the
portland and miami game and
we want to salute christian james
mccullum
thank you for the three by two take a
look
cj what do you got for us homie
splash my guy's just a bucket
cj mccullum had six three-pointers in
this game
another bucket thank you for the three
by two my dude
that was a win so today we asked you on
twitter the 3x2 was back tonight which
one of these games is your favorite bet
nets versus hornets or clippers versus
nuggets those are the games on the tnt
schedule
what do you like the results please
64 a rocker with the hornets at the nets
that is the lock for tonight we
appreciate you guys for for voting
uh g-money and we know you like your arm
and we know you like your winners only
so please assemble them
and we need to know which game we're
riding with that's just the poll on
twitter
but what does the audience want tonight
g-money all right let me talk to the
people let me talk to the people here's
what i need you guys to do
we have charlotte versus brooklyn denver
versus the clippers los angeles clippers
uh you guys let me know which 3x2 should
we ride should we ride
brooklyn charlotte denver los angeles
clippers
you guys let me know get in the comments
fill them up give me gifts emojis text
type it out whatever however you want to
do it fill those comments up
but kelly which one do you
think we should ride which way are you
leaning i went back and forth
on both of these games i couldn't really
decide then i started looking at
defensive efficiency and the nets
are atrocious so i said okay fine
i'll take the worst defense it looks so
obvious but i gotta go
with charlotte and brooklyn here maybe
we can see
uh this charlotte team take advantage of
no james harden early hit a couple easy
buckets and we cashed this ticket
i'm right there with you i like that
this charlotte hornets did they won
three games on the three straight games
on the road brooklyn is a top three
three-point shooting team and that's
largely due to joe harris who's shooting
it 49 percent from downtown
but if charlotte if terry rozier or
devonta graham just get it started you
know what i think charlotte will just do
it on it's
do it on their own so graham scary terry
i'm looking at you
charlotte versus brooklyn that's a three
by two tonight
g money what's the audience say which
game do they like uh
cabbie finally i get to introduce it to
the audience
guys this is the handy dandy ipad this
is how you get your hoodies
i am in the comments cabbie i got hga
baller saying
rock with the nets tonight the nets in
charlotte
okay shout out to you hga baller uh i
have
the brain hold on hold on the the brains
pick
says denver uh los angeles clippers
shout out to you brains picks
flex too much clippers ain't doing she's
for the three by two so that mean that
they are not rocking with the clippers
in the three by two
uh max spitz max spit says nets hornets
zack mei 10 is rocking with brooklyn and
joe harris
shout out to everybody that i just
mentioned you guys are walking away with
a hoodie also
luke luke x10 shout out to you he says
horn it's nets
so uh i guess i'm rocking with the
people guys like i guess i'm rocking
with the people wait hold on there's one
more one more one more one more
yeah one more one more cabbie one more
cabbie i got
uh i got zach
no no go m gold blue m gold blue he says
uh charlotte brooklyn i'm rocking with
you guys
he's having a trouble a little bit of
trouble there because he's trying to
sift through all those vegas greg
comments i told everybody who's getting
hoodies
there's literally not no vegas greg
it's endless we need we need vegas greg
in the comments
uh so check out brbr socials for the
link to the three by two offered
on fanduel uh six months ago kawhi
leonard and nicola yokic
faced off in an epic seven game series
in the bubble
where the denver nuggets climbed back
from a 3-1
deficit to beat the clippers the
clippers
the the latest team to blow a 3-1 lead
salute to your golden state warriors
d-money
and then on christmas day kawhi leonard
dropped 21 points in a win
joker had 24 and a loss they match up
tonight
the fun guy versus the joker
the question is who will score more
points
kawhi or nicola jokic g-money who do you
like in this matchup or who does the
army like in this particular matchup
cabbie let me ask him hey guys what i
need you guys to do is let me know
get in the comments who's going to score
more points gifts only
we're looking for gifts only here really
i love it kawhi
leonard or will it be the joker you guys
let me know get in the comments
kelly you had a joker
uh a jokic futures mvp ticket last year
this year he might win the war
who are you betting on to score more
kawhi
or nicola you're right i was a year late
to the or
you're early excuse me you're always
ahead of the game
always ahead of the game can't catch a
ticket no all jokes aside i looked at
this and i said look
the joker get in plus 142 looks like
great value
but this clippers defense has really
stepped up over the last few games
i think hawaii's the favorite here for a
reason 184 makes me
like makes my skin crawl it's like the
last thing i want to take
and whenever something like that happens
it's usually for a reason i'm going to
take kawhi
uh this team this nuggets team number
six and points allowed
but i i think that clippers aren't gonna
give up these like offensive rebounds i
don't think the joker is gonna get these
easy buckets like he's used to getting
i think kawhi is gonna have himself a
day i'm on the other side of this one
kel's
jokic is a point center and denver just
traded for aaron gordon so naturally
jokic is going to look to get aaron
gordon activated in the offense
and all game you know aaron gordon and
michael porter jr will be will be thrown
at kawhi listen they don't play
great defense but they're going to slow
him down a little bit but the bigger
question is
who's going to guard the yoke the the
joker for 36 minutes
on the clippers nobody so i'm i'm going
with nikola jokic
all day in this head-to-head matchup
give me the joker
over kawhi to score more points tonight
do you mind do you have either of these
players on your fantasy team
uh cabbie i do not i don't have either
of these players on my fantasy team
speaking of fantasy go but i haven't
even
been participating in my fantasy league
the commissioner actually hit me up the
other day
and told me hey man uh playoffs are
coming up these games are starting to
get uh
you know uh interesting so we i need you
to fill your lineup and so i gotta get
on it but no
neither of these two are uh on my team
but let me get into these comments gabby
let me get into these comments
i got chris 12 see he got the hey hey
hey he said you know the
yeah here we go vixen three vixen three
is rocking with you cabbies rocking with
the joker
i got nada waffles also rocking with the
joker shout out to you
mgino mgno 99 he's rocking with the
joker
uh cabbie it's a runaway they're right
they love that plus money
they are riding with italia italy a
tally
it says yokitch all day yeah cabbie it's
a it's a landslide it is a landslide
uh are you guessing are you on youtube
i guess that means i'm rocking with you
i mean to be honest cabbie you made a
real good point
who's gonna guard him zubots patrick
peters like who's gonna guard him
yeah he's gonna be patrick peterson
actually greg who's got a guard
that's that's barbecue chicken
patterson on uh yeah and pete peterson
the free safety where where did peterson
land he's no longer
the cardinals right patrick peters
anyway it's patrick patterson
former kentucky guy yeah but you're
right is he gonna guard jokic for 30
minutes tonight
not likely and he's not even that good
uh anyway listen if you didn't get uh if
you don't get a hoodie
right now by greg calling out your name
you can type in with us on the community
stream on the br app
fire off your takes there we're giving
out hoodies all night
on the way to making good decisions you
got to make a couple of bad ones
and every year mba general managers
they you know they run through their
simulations they do the risk versus
reward assessments and they shoot their
shots around nba trade deadline day
orlando unloaded all of its stars victor
oladipo finally ended up in miami
and kyle lowry remained a toronto raptor
so the question to you greg is after
after a week
the dust the dust has settled on the nba
trade deadline
have you changed your mind as far as who
is winning the east
no why would i do that cabbie what like
so you're sticking with the brooklyn
nets
like why would i do that do you not just
see who else came onto their team like
a couple weeks ago like i mean within
the week they got lamarcus
audrey's blake griffin along with the
big three like why would i
cabbie come on man why would i do that
uh let me let let me ask the people let
me ask let me get into the comments let
me ask these
uh the the the the people the audience
uh who do you guys think is going to win
the east
who's who's going to win these talk to
me who do you guys think is going to win
he's get creative
uh kelly did any trades
change your mind about which team's
winning these did any of these trades
change your mind because we got a bet we
also got another bet i don't i don't
know if you guys remember this is this
me and kelly me and kelly got a bet that
the brooklyn nets finished in the top
four
of the eastern conference in the uh
three i said they won't finish in the
top three so if they're fourth
i win they're not going to be fourth
miami's too many games back but you know
who's not that many games back
the milwaukee bucks and the 76ers 76ers
are gonna have joel embiid back on
saturday it sounds like
you know who's not going to be back on
saturday james harden or kevin durant
look for this nets team to kind of take
a back seat here they may end up in
second place
in the east before it's all said and
done if they end up in third place
i won't beat myself up too bad for my
bad nets take
i wish they that's gonna be sorry that's
that wasn't that's another 500 bet do
you money
yeah it's another five that's yeah it's
another five you
you would tease earlier is there a cash
out option on this bet or no
yeah i mean they are number one right
now all right kelly i'll give you a cash
out option
of 4.95 with 95 cents uh you could take
that right now
i'd rather keep my original bet i'd
rather just keep my original
better than miami heat at 14-1 and hope
these kids can just keep trending
upwards
hey salute to victor oladipo we'll see
what happens i my original pick was the
philadelphia 76ers and if they landed
kyle lowry
the six-time all-star the nba champion
that would have been a home run
for philly there was there were some
rumors that the sixers and daryl murray
didn't want to part with
matisse steibel and tyrese maxie and a
couple of first-round picks
but so messiah lord eugeri stood pat
held on to kyle lowry if they got listen
that would have been
i know it's opening day in baseball
landing kyle lowry would have been a
ryan howard home run
but they landed george hill who's a nice
veteran piece he's a night he's a solid
player
that's like a bryce harper double so i'm
going to stick with
my philadelphia pick i like miami like
oladipo wants to be there
didn't want to be in houston going to be
renewed so miami is a scary scary team
but i'm gonna stick with my original
sixers pick
uh g-money is any is is the audience
riding with you in brooklyn or
are we seeing some other teams um that
are
that they're they're liking to come out
of the east in the finals matchup
i will follow one says nix he's rocking
what the next shot i think i will follow
hey if you guys are just repeating
comments i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna unless they say vegas greg
if you're just repeating vegas greg over
the entire comment section i'm gonna
give you a hoodie that's the
nick hasn't given out one hoodie so
don't listen
like don't listen to that here we go
chris 12c soraka with brooklyn
shouts out to you chris jrj93 is rocking
with brooklyn smart man
shouts out to you stiney 88 rocking with
brooklyn shouts out to you steiny
everybody that said you're walking away
with hoodie and i'm not done jerome
aguilar is rocking with the nets
shouts out to you you're walking away
everybody's on the net
yeah it seems like it demur murph 66
he said uh he's rocking with the harness
but i think that he's talking about for
the game tonight
the murph you got to get with the
program get with the program but you're
still walking
away with the hoodie shouts out to you
uh cabbie
let's so let's move it over to the
western conference the top four teams
the jazz
the suns the lakers and the clippers did
not make any moves
at the deadline although the lakers did
acquire uh
andre drummond as a free agent in the
buyout market
um but um did the lakers blow up by not
making any moves
with lebron and anthony davis injured
and do the nuggets have a shot with
aaron gordon here are
the odds in the western conference
g-money who do you have coming out of
the west
uh cabbie you see that team that's
second uh
by the name of the los angeles clippers
i was heavy on them last year
very heavy on them last year uh in the
bubble you know things happen
things did happen they got a new coach
regrouped i see them
getting healthy they're not healthy
right now getting healthy and not making
a push
that's what i'm rocking with but hold on
let me ask the audience
here's what i need you guys to do get in
the comments get in the comments tell me
who you
are riding with to win the west now
kelly you have a jazz tickets
jazz futures ticket since the lakers got
uh bigger with drummond are you worried
about la making it out of the west
one i want to give finn sanity five i'm
gonna give finn sanity five
uh a shout out give him a hoodie
whoever's in charge just here to watch
kelly's school greg
and the rest of you i'm really
disappointed because nobody there
follows directions
so i have a nice little ticket on the
jazz they're sitting in first place
they're on cruise control
sun's coming in hot coming in hot not
gonna lie that worries me i am not
worried about the clippers and i am most
certainly
not worried about the los angeles lakers
lebron james what are we talking cabbie
four to six weeks maybe yeah
yep the heist oh look guess what the
playoffs start in seven weeks so
i'm gonna go ahead and say i don't think
the lakers are gonna make some big push
this next six weeks i like where i'm
sitting with the jazz in cruise control
uh i made a mistake the the lakers did
make a move with the trade deadline they
got the
they got playoff rondo rajon rondo they
traded with the
atlanta hawks obviously an nba champion
with the lakers last year and formerly
with the boston celtics
might be a critical piece or may not
may not be a that much of a contributor
we will see
i was originally on the lakers but as
kelly mentioned the high ankle sprain
from lebron james we've seen it in the
nfl
like with saquon barkley and christian
mccaffrey those guys were out for a
legit six weeks with a high ankle sprain
and they weren't the same when they came
back either rushing to get back too
early like barkley
or just mccaffrey last year just wasn't
the same so i have my concerns
with la and anthony davis he's got a
hamstring he's got a calf strain he's
got an achilles
one tweak and it's a wrap for the lakers
so
i like the portland trail blazers the
norm powell piece
these guys can score like crazy that's
gonna
i know we don't do upset specials
because it's not that tournament
but i like the portland trailblazers as
a dark horse
uh in the western conference g-money you
you said you're you're riding with your
lakers
um no no no the clippers oh sorry your
clippers excuse me yes sir is the
audience
does the audience also believe that
whoever will represent the west
will be playing out of the staples
center ah cabbie they're all over the
place i got deep
geeks in jazz plus 440 is straight up
robbery shout out to you
uh d geek uh johnny ballgame 77 says
sun's defense is sick i don't know if
that means he's
rocking with them to win the west but
he's uh mentioning their defense so
shout out to you
johnny ball game uh athletes of christ
says maverick's going to make a run with
doncic
going into mvp form cash it wow
all right athletes of christ uh shout
out to you i did see you call me vegas
greg so i don't know if i want to give
you that hoodie
i'm actually gonna think about that one
uh here we go
mr real fanatic somebody has to prove to
me that they can beat the lakers in
seven
games series uh so lakers if they're at
least 85 percent healthy because nobody
is 100
healthy in the playoffs that is a great
take mr real
fantastic you are walking away with a
hoodie uh cabbie
i think i'm done i think i think i'm
done uh
there it's a mixture it's a mixture you
as you can see
it's up it's up for grabs this here is
up for grabs and who's winning the west
we don't know
lebron in them is hurt right now all
right the the jazz getting no love the
suns are getting no love you're on the
clippers
lakers getting a light you're right the
west the west is wide open
um emotionally we we we were wide open
last week we uh
the family uh the family we almost were
almost torn apart
um it got heated like godzilla versus
king kong
it just you know the beast came you know
and for the record
uh g-money you're godzilla because
godzilla lives in the bay and he's super
vibey
but um after 13 weeks uh greg
finally hit a five leg same game parlay
yes and uh and he got he got free from
you know listen it was it was like it
was like the ever given cargo ship
trying to get through the suez canal it
took
13 weeks and finally g-money got free
kelly paid him 500 bucks immediately
and uh and i just want to say something
i just want you to know
13 weeks 50 a week plus his parlay
payout plus
my 50 bucks greg didn't even break even
but that's beside the point sorry
i don't i don't want to talk about the
650 and then oh they earned 500 so
down 150 yeah it's all good and last
week too we actually took a shot
and that one hit kells are we we have do
we have a family therapy
session uh booked with dr mikey locks or
dr vern
or are we are we good dr vern
dr vern he's very why is he still in the
group chat i'm gonna kick him out i
think i started that group chat i'm
gonna have the ability to kick him out
so greg you floated the idea last week
that kelly should try
a five leg same game parlay uh where are
we at with that
yeah i mean i think we should just let
that happen
my why not i mean i want kelly to use
our spreadsheets
i want her to use her numbers and i
wanted to use her research
to uh see how difficult or how easy it
is
to hit one of these five game five same
game
parlays all right so cows it's uh uh
hornets nets is is the 7 30 game is this
the one you're locking in to try this
five leg parlay
our producer said this is the game i
have to pick i took a little bit of time
this morning
with two things as you know a five team
uh
same game parlay if you
actually just did a five teamer at any
sports book everything minus 110 and
pays 22 to one
that's just not acceptable in my world
so if i'm gonna do a five teamers gotta
pay at least 50 to one
i found some really nice plus money
nuggets i also found out you can't take
any under so i was making fun of greg
this whole time and
i like the under tonight which made this
even more difficult because
i'm when you're doing a parlay you want
to figure out how you think the game is
going to go
and then you want to plug and play how
you think the game progresses so i
am starting off with the under 2 24 and
a half and
then that makes everything else really
difficult nets
i think have been known as this very
elusive over team they hit
overs there right when james harden came
in and guess what
regression is a [ __ ] because eight of
their last 10 have gone under
i like tonight's under especially
without james harden speaking of no
james harden
the hornets open plus three they would
have been a much bigger dog
in brooklyn and i think there was some
overreaction there but i did still think
the hornets were going to win the game
the cool thing about fanduel and they
offer the margin of victory so i chose
hornet's win by one to ten
at almost two to one instead of taking
the hornets plus 130 on the money line
so i thought that was really kind of a
cool thing
and then i looked at this net scene and
i said okay look in the last 10 games
they've at least
allowed one 20-point score who's that
going to be
and kathy i know you love scary terry
and i looked at him
but him at over 20 was still minus 190
and then i looked at over 25 and i go
man i got the under the last thing i
really want to happen here is somebody
to put up 25.
so i started looking at gordon hayward
so i took gordon hayward over
20 points and this is when it gets real
dicey because these are nice
decent plus monies but i think that
they're worth it here to give this
parlay a little extra juice
pj washington over eight rebounds i know
the nets don't give up a ton of boards
but neither do the suns and my dude got
12 rebounds against the suns last week i
think that he is a man on a mission here
he's playing great defense
i want to see him go after get some
boards and last but not least devonte
graham
over six assists now hear me out he only
averages four and a half
assists per game but the nets give up a
ton of assists i think he's gonna come
he's gonna be a terrific teammate
tonight and help out
his fellow hornets players
okay so i'm i'm curious you said you
like 50 to one parlays like what is the
ticket on this particular
uh five legger this one actually pays 55
to one so if you guys follow me during
college football i look for those
three team money line parlays three dogs
that have a chance to win out right
so when i put this together this is what
a five team parlay
in my opinion should look like it should
be at least
22 to one not less than even money but
hey
here we are isn't even 55 to one it's
54.
like what what do you mean it's
basically what it's called
i'm sorry that i'm nine dollars and
seventy seven cents short
oh mom it's basically gonna be fine you
know
this is a lot what you know what you
know what though
i'm gonna change the juju i'm gonna
change the vibes i'm not gonna be like
you guys and be salty and say oh
you know this isn't gonna hit this isn't
gonna i'm
definitely not gonna i'm actually gonna
encourage you kelly i'm gonna encourage
you no i don't want you
i don't want that i'm gonna give you
happiness i'm gonna give you guys
where is kyrie irving with the sage when
i need him i don't need any
vibes i'm trying to give you this good
vibe so
so this parlay can hit because i know
it's really not but i just want to
give you the vibes to try so it can hit
okay so then i'm gonna i'm gonna play
the role of the person
who comes in with the bad vibes pj
washington is the rim protector for
charlotte
and eight plus rebounds is within reach
but with claxton and aldridge is gonna
be available tonight and bruce brown
it's that's gonna be a tight one to get
eight rebounds
uh for the hornets the rest of the
ticket i really like devante graham
hopefully will be a great distributor
and maybe rozzier will get five assists
as well and they'll spread the ball
around
but so washington like that i think is
going to be the diciest
but it's a good looking ticket you and
i'll be watching the game
uh on the nba bet stream i'm excited
with our friends from fanduel so i will
be cheering for all of these things
uh in some sort of capacity over the
next few hours at
7 30 p.m eastern it's uh tntdrama.com
tnt tntbets uh thank you for watching
for tapping into the group show
tonight presented by fanduel if you want
more group chat action
you just hop into the hop into sports
betting hit the community tab
and then follow along the the hornets
and the
hornets in the nets game with us tonight
and if you want more hoodies
um get in that community uh tab right
now fire off some hot takes
because we're giving away a few more
hoodies remember what you learned here
today
if you like some value in the eastern
conference and the western conference
which is wide open there's still some
value plays
so lock them in with seven weeks left to
go in the season and uh
you can find some gems some bedding gems
in that community tab
under the bleacher in the bleacher
report app my name is kathy richards
alongside our betting expert
kelly stewart and vegas greg we are
leaving the group chat
thanks for joining this piece vegas g
no no
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign